guys new trash taste merch is available
right now this is not a drill good
check it out
I have new clothes finally I am
practically coming and you will be too
when you get your hands on this trash
taste merch guys check out this design
look at this
[Music]
um shooting myself in excitement right
now look at that look at my design as
well look at this look at this oh my oh
my God
and of course don't forget about our
brand new sweater as well look at this
[ __ ] look at that it's beautiful I
didn't know this bad boy is gonna last
but ladies and gentlemen be warned you
only have three weeks as of today three
get your hands on it three whole weeks
that's not a lot of time now you know
how many people missed out on our last
drop and you don't want to miss out on
this one guys it's already waiting for
smash that link in the description down
below to get your trash taste merch
today we're back baby wake up
subscribers put a little makeup all
right guys well so when I say the one
piece no you say it's real
foreign
ladies and gentlemen welcome to another
episode of the trash taste podcast it's
me Joey and I'm with Garden Corner as
always and we are back hey we are back
in Japan it's probably gonna feel like
that because the episodes have been
coming out as no for you guys it's been
uh one episode per week as per usual for
us it has been over two months this is
the first Trash taste time skit
it is the trash taste time skip uh we've
gone through our America Arc uh that
hasn't aired yet so I mean we all got
haircuts I've noticed actually I haven't
yeah
I desperately needed that yeah so
frankly but gentlemen I had the worst
taxi ride of my life oh we're just gonna
get straight into it never left I you
know I was um okay so I'll lay the scene
for you right so I have a shoot at 1 30
p.m okay right so I got to be there a
little bit early right I'm trying to get
there one one fifteen but I'm like you
know if I get there one five one ten
I'll just get a coffee somewhere nearby
yeah out so I I schedule my taxi right
uh schedule if I'm super British
schedule so I schedule it right so that
I can get there at latest 1 15. yeah
give me a 15 minute buff up trying to be
professional trying to be great so I
call this taxi right and it's like it's
like a Japanese kind of uber version app
and it normally takes at most 15 minutes
so I schedule a taxi or whatever it is
the point is that I'm like buffering on
buffers right so I call the cab at 12
30. it's a 20 minute Journey so I have
plenty of time if it's like the maximum
I I might even get there completely far
too early right so I I get the app and
it's and I I call the taxi and Boom at
12 30 I have a taxi driver who's
arriving in 15 minutes yeah that's a 20
minute Journey so the taxi should arrive
at 12 45 and then I'll get there at 105.
right a little bit early but fine it's
fine okay
so I have 15 minutes so I go and I go
and brush my teeth I go and start
getting ready and I go and check my
phone 10 minutes later and he hasn't
moved it's still 15 minutes away and I
can see that he's beginning he's been
going up and down this one road and I'm
like I'm sure it's nothing I'm sure I'm
sure it's fine
listen I'm sure I'm sure you know he
just got a little lost on this one road
it's a main road you know maybe you just
couldn't get off it right it's no big
deal sure I should have canceled right
then and there I most certainly should
have and I so regret it right I had the
thought in my head I'm sure this is
nothing right and I should have listened
to myself and realized this was a sign
of things to come so to to get to my my
where I am there's a series of like
one-way roads that are a bit confusing
and they they have to enter at this
certain point if they don't enter at a
certain point it's like it adds five to
ten minutes of [ __ ] to try and get
back to where I am right yeah so he's
coming up to it and I'm waiting outside
and if he gets if he gets this turn you
can comes to me I'm ready to go of
course he [ __ ] misses it just goes
right past it even though the navigation
tells him where to go and I'm like
whatever it's fine okay it's almost like
GPS's were invented for a reason I know
I know I know there are a lot too far
there are a lot of times tribes in Japan
who take GPS as a suggestion yeah um so
it's whatever it's happened before I'm
not a bit it's not a big deal yeah a
circle around he'll come but it adds
five minutes right yeah so again so
we're all he's already 10 minutes later
than he's supposed to be and now it's
five minutes so what he should have been
here 15 minutes now it's 30. so and now
just about be on time
so he he finally gets here and you know
I I understand sometimes they can't find
the exact location where you tell them
to pick you up from [ __ ] didn't
even try he was like three blocks away
and then press the I'm here button so
then I had five minutes to get to him
otherwise it starts it cancels it or
charges me money yeah yeah so I'm like
what the [ __ ] so I'm rushing to get to
him and then I finally get to the car
with like one minute remaining on this
timer otherwise my journey gets canceled
and I get charged money yeah and he's
not even in the [ __ ] car
he's a gun somewhere
walking around like where where is this
guy yeah so I'm just sitting there and
then finally he comes and I he obviously
realized that he [ __ ] up so he was
around looking for me
yeah yeah yeah yeah whatever whatever
okay it's a bit weird a little
uncomfortable and I've got a shoot to be
to and I I this is a very precisely
timed thing that I can't miss yeah we
have one hour and everyone's waiting on
me it's and like the venue that we're
filming at is gonna open at three so we
only have that one hour window to film
sure so
I'm like whatever it's fine I'll be on
time this is weird and so I get in the
car
and this is when I started to get
worried
he kind of just sits in the in the
driver's seat for about 30 seconds
and he goes oh where are you going
I was like what okay what are you where
am I going I'm like it's on the app and
I'm like I pull out my phone I'm like
it's on the app when I ordered you on
yeah yeah and this guy wasn't a normal
taxi driver because he didn't have in
Japan if you're a taxi driver there's
got to be a bunch of identification yeah
and stuff on the window to kind of let
you know who who's driving you and what
company they work for in case you have a
complaint or something you didn't have
any of that so it was clearly a private
hire only right so this guy only works
through this app and maybe he's new or
something or I don't know and I'm like
whatever it's fine yeah I'm like well
yeah look at the app I said use the
navigation on the App please and you're
telling him how to do his job where do
we go to be fair a lot of the taxi
drivers like to clarify that you put the
right address yeah yeah because I've had
it where I've put it in wrong yeah and
I'll correct him and I'll be like oh
actually no it's here yeah this didn't
seem like that but it wasn't like that
at all yeah so I'm like I'm like show
them the fun I'm like oh this navigation
please use this one right so he grabs my
phone even though he has it on an iPad
right here that is much bigger than my
phone it starts basically zooming in on
where I told him to go right and I'm
telling him I'm like oh oh no no that's
that's not going to help you because I'm
in like a it's in like a really weird
Alleyway yeah it's like it's not going
to help you and so he's looking at it
frantically zooming in and he's like
yeah I don't know where this is I'm like
well that's why you listen to the air
that's why there's a GPS telling you
where to go I know you know again I'm
being polite about it I'm like all right
this is whatever and be quite quiet I'm
just telling her I just kept telling him
like please use the app yeah please use
the app navigation and and so and then
he's he's trying to read the address on
the thing and it's because it's in
English I'm like I I tell him the
address yeah and so now he starts
putting it in and I'm like again I
remind him like you can just use the app
yeah just use the app like it's right
like it tells you where to go and you
put the address in but put it in wrong
oh my God I'm like no that's wrong
that's not where I'm going
this is the address I'm sorry I'm trying
to like kind of like talk him through
this yeah and he finally gets the
address right and then he puts it in on
his iPhone and I it was really odd
because I was trying to speak to him in
Japanese but he clearly didn't speak
much Japanese either okay uh he I think
he was Chinese right because I heard his
like iPhone telling him his stuff it was
really confusing right um and I was like
whatever well I mean we're both trying
to figure out a halfway language here to
communicate first
um and so
he finally finally starts the car and
he's put the navigation in and now I'm
going to be just on time if things go
right right yeah but he's been taking so
long to get started in this car that a
giant truck has parked in front of us
and there's a car behind us and this guy
is clearly not confident enough to get
out of this parallel park situation
um so he just kind of sits there for
five minutes okay I'm getting to the
point where I'll drive [ __ ] it just give
me I'll get it I'll do it so waiting for
five minutes yeah to get out for to wait
for one of these guys to move like he
could have if he wanted to he wanted to
be like faster about it he could have
asked the guy in front to move up a
little bit but I think he was a bit
nervous I seemed really nervous about
the whole thing
um and so finally the car behind us
moves
and now he has to reverse and for some
reason this is like a hard task he can't
reverse the car
it's just not happening and I'm sitting
there awkwardly listening this beep beep
and we're just not moving okay he's like
looking behind
looking behind look at the screen
looking behind for about the most
awkward two minutes of my life right but
he keeps looking behind and not moving
right and then he goes ah
restarts the car I'm like what is that
what's happening what is happening did
he literally just do a turn and off and
on again
he restarts the car right and then now
we reverse and I'm like okay this is
weird so we start driving and the
shooting I would run about 30 seconds
and he's fiddling with something on the
iPad
he's looking at this iPad non-stop all
right and suddenly get a notification on
my phone your ride has ended
what's that what did it just give up I
think he accidentally pressed end right
right and now I'm like what happens now
because he just started driving right
yeah and now I'm like uh uh uh and so he
starts driving and I'm trying to figure
out what the [ __ ] do I do like I'm yeah
I'm like I don't know if I'm gonna be
late where's he going yeah yeah I'm like
does he need so he has to he has the
navigation in his phone right but I'm
like I'm like worried now he ended the
ride on Uber right yeah basically so I'm
like what what happens now like I didn't
know what to do and I was trying to
figure out what I said
yeah and so I I was thinking like man
what should I do should I just like let
him keep driving or should I should I
ask him to stop at some point like
because because they've already been
charged yeah like the full amount of the
trip is like it's prepaid right yeah so
I've already been charged for it so he
has to take you there yeah but he on his
thing it'll say that like he didn't take
me there so it's really like I'm I'm
just unsure what to do because I'm
pretty sure I'm not gonna be able to get
a refund yeah so I'm kind of like okay
[ __ ] it I'm sure he'll get me there and
this won't be a problem yeah I should
have got the [ __ ] out of the car right
so right to leave my house there is like
you can go straight and it'll turn
around and there's a or there's a right
turn you can do oh sorry a left turn you
can do right away yeah and he has to
just go straight right and of course
just immediately turns and I'm like no
no even though the sat nav is telling
him to just go straight he just ignores
it right and I'm like oh no oh no this
is going to keep happening isn't it and
I [ __ ] you not every single turn he
ignored okay every single one and then
the writers were pulling out of my place
to go onto a main road he nearly hits a
car like straight up like this car's
going really fast and he's just going
into traffic and I'm like
I'm a genuine like a fearing for my life
now this guy can't listen to the sat nav
he seems to be [ __ ] up everything
yeah and can't reverse can't reverse
nearly driving into traffic and he he
refuses refuses to listen to his own
navigation okay and it is stressing me
out because now I'm I see that every
single turn he misses two minutes adds
up right right four minutes five minutes
ten minutes he there was one point where
he just had to keep going straight and
he just decided to turn and then
realized he [ __ ] up and added on five
minutes trying to do a U-turn and I'm
like I'm gonna die like what what why
though like I don't know did he think it
was like oh I'll take this foreign
[Music]
and it seemed as if he would only take
turns
from what I noticed if they were like
clean corner turns right like if he had
to go into traffic to do wide turns yeah
he wouldn't take it he would ignore it
right and I was like
should you does he have a driver's
license yeah yeah kind of sounding like
he doesn't have a driver's license
running through my mind right and so
he's like zoolanders like I can only
turn
it's like it's literally like Zoolander
he would only do the like the if you're
in America like the right turns yeah
yeah he wouldn't do any turns that were
wide and kind of into traffic yeah I was
just making me like I'm like oh my God
this guy is like so instead of just
going straight to my destination on a
map he's doing like this right only
doing like back alleys and small turns
right and at one point he's he he
realizes right that the the ride has
been ended right and so he keeps
fiddling with the iPad looking at it but
he's driving the whole time and it's on
his chair on the passenger seat so it's
not like he's looking looking at
something on the dashboard like this
he's like this
oh my God and and at multiple points we
were like in full-on moving traffic and
he was like
yeah and you know I politely asked him I
was like hey um can you look at the road
yeah because I was like this is Beth
like at one point yeah we were it was
like the traffic had backed up so we
were like we weren't near the lights we
were in the middle of the road there was
a lot of traffic and all the cars
started going and for about five seconds
he was still looking at the iPad now to
be like excuse me excuse me you've got
to go yeah and he was like oh oh yeah
sorry sorry sorry it was this whole
awkward mess where he just everything he
could have possibly done wrong he did
wrong everything everything and this is
and this was supposed to be a taxi ride
that went for how long it was a 20
minute ride yeah and the taxi ride
itself not including all the [ __ ] we had
before yeah it ended up being 15 minutes
so from 20 minutes to 50 minutes because
he just kept taking all the wrong turns
right yeah and we and just walked there
yeah yeah honestly honestly and at the
end of it I was just like dreading that
he was gonna be like hey the ride ended
are we gonna have to fix this yeah and I
was just like the whole time I was like
please please just let me out of this
taxi you don't keep me in here and
talking to me I was just terrified that
I was gonna have to like have a
confrontation with him right about it
because I just didn't want to obviously
he's had [ __ ] to do yeah and luckily we
finally got there and he was the one
time he was going to listen to the
navigation was when it was actually
going to be less efficient for my
journey and I was like no no just just
keep going straight keep going straight
please please please and it's right as
we were getting to the end and thank God
he listened and he let me out and that
was the end of it but oh my God I was so
stressed because I was late to my shoot
by 20 minutes yeah and I had to like
just fumble my way into it and get
started right away right yeah bro damn
Nightmare and I hate I hate rating
people poorly on these apps because I
because you know I'm like maybe it's
just a one-off maybe it is right maybe
this didn't sound like it was a one no
but it sounded like this guy yeah I mean
afterwards I was like no I can't I can't
there's no excuse in my mind that can
justify how much this guy [ __ ]
everything out I mean if he told me he
was an alien who just landed on those
yesterday I would believe it
and so the whole ride in the day I was
just trying to figure out like what was
that dude's deal
what was up with this I mean I've you
know I've been in a couple of Taxi rides
where you know it's usually because you
know yeah yeah yeah you know Japanese
taxi is usually like an older gentleman
you know who is like very much like
anti-technology and he's like no no no
I've lived in this area for 60 years I
know the road's better than any sack
yeah and then you know they clearly miss
a very simple turn yeah but like that
didn't seem like that yeah it seemed
like he'd I don't know if he just moved
here recently or something and he wasn't
familiar with the roads and maybe he was
scared of using them and it might have
just started but either way I knew I
mean you shouldn't be driving taxes if
you're scared of the road no there's
there's a minimum requirement to a job
of just being a taxi driver even if it
is kind of like I don't know because
it's kind of like the app is kind of
like uber but I don't know what their
requirements for [ __ ] uh clearly none
yeah I know I know that it's you know
becoming a taxi driver in Japan is not
hard but I mean it's not hard already
anywhere
um you live long enough
we're gonna see
I don't know you know not to blame the
foreigners
sometimes I felt bad for the guy because
he clearly seemed like he was
overwhelmed and I know I hate piling on
[ __ ] people who already look like
they're not handling stuff well yeah but
at the same time it's like there's a
limit yeah there's a limit to what I
think is like you should not be doing
this yeah like you and also your life is
in your his hands yeah the moment he
nearly crashed is when I was kind of
like all right this is too much now yeah
like this is like I I I I you just
you're actively like a danger yeah yeah
not only are you awful at this job from
like an efficiency standpoint you are
actively like harmful like damn we
haven't been back in Japan for a while
and it seems like you've already gone
into some like [ __ ] yeah yeah I mean
you know because sometimes uh in Japan
like more often not public transport is
quicker but depending on where you live
and how the roots are sometimes you
might have to change like three or four
times for a 30 minute Journey yeah of
course and the taxi will be one ride 15
minutes boom you're right there yeah
yeah so a lot of the time like I'll just
do that because like I don't want to
have to deal with it especially if it's
like you know 15-20 minutes away right
most of the time if you go via app
that's when you like don't [ __ ] up you
know because you can time it perfectly
yeah because the driver always follows
the app you know it's it's for the most
part for the most part you know a lot of
the times it's very common if you get in
the taxi in Japan they'll and you've
ordered it on an app they'll be a firm
they'll be like are you going here and
you say yeah and then they'll be like
cool and they they'll they I get this
ass quite a lot they'll be like do you
want me to use the navigation in the app
oh yeah yes please yeah I put it in for
a reason
yeah it's been like no no no I I trust
yours Yeah because sometimes the app
doesn't like include highways and
highways and tolls and so they have to
manually add the toll costs onto the
price that you didn't see right so
there's a lot of there's a lot of stuff
that you might not know if you're not in
living in Japan using taxis often yeah
the taxis have some form of etiquette
and you mean it's it's a bit different
from like New York and other places in
the world yeah but I feel if you're
visiting and stuff you know the the
train system is 99.9 full proof so oh
yeah yeah the trip might be a little bit
you know longer and more tedious
especially if you need to like change
train stations on the way but for the
most part it's fairly simple yeah if you
need to get somewhere fast and from a
location there's not a train station
taxis are like often very of course yeah
well I I feel like if you know if if you
don't know how to like talk to a lot of
taxi drivers I actually feel like trains
for sure for sure yeah because taxi
drivers will ask you like a lot if it's
not like a train station or if it's not
like a major Monumental that's that's
the one thing I hate about catching a
taxi in Japan it's like when whenever
it's like I missed like I mean you know
I missed the last train yeah taxi home
right and then you know I tell them like
where I need to go and he puts it in the
sat nav and then he's like
um so do you want me to go down like
this specific route and I'm like I don't
[ __ ] know I get that as well because
like sometimes I get a taxi and they're
like um I'm thinking about going this
way do you know if I can do that or not
I'm like I'm not the [ __ ] taxi driver
I don't know my way I always just say
please use whatever navigation tool you
have I I tell them my simple trick is I
just tell them go the shortest drought
yeah yeah I'm like I don't care just
just take me home I need to be home
right because sometimes if it's not on
an app and you just call a taxi they
don't put it in the SAT like the
navigation but they'll ask you like
[ __ ] 20 questions and be like can I
go this way I'm like it's two in the
morning I'm shit-faced I don't know
where I am I just want to be home just
take me home unless it's like a very
well-known Monument or a place I
normally always just say hey can you put
in the address and then they'll pull up
the SAT and everything yeah
[Music]
and then just read it out to them that's
pretty useful I have uh I have a
similarly like kind of funny story uh
that happened just the other night um so
you know we just got back from a tour
which we'll obviously talk about later
in the show yeah but um you know I
wanted to like catch up with some
friends because I haven't seen them in a
while right and we're doing a meet-up uh
in Syria and uh this is like you know
there's a couple of izakayas that me and
my group of friends like going to you
know just for a big group meet up
because it's you know it's especially
like on like a Friday night or whatever
most isakizen is in inches yeah
[Music]
I know of a couple of like you know kind
of hidden spots that usually are quite
free even on weekends so we went there
and you know we were just like drinking
chatting away and we were the only ones
there to begin with right and we were
like oh this is great we got the whole
place to ourselves
um and then just like I don't know maybe
two three hours into the night uh this
huge group of people just start walking
like I want to say like 50 to 100 people
Jesus just like all like you know yeah
like five people at a time and that's 10
people and then it's five people and
then before you know it this entire
place is packed with people just like
standing around drinking and stuff like
that
um you know but it's like whatever we
got the we got our seats we're having
fun it's all good yeah and then about 20
minutes in I just kind of like noticed
I'm like man it's really quiet
why is it so quiet and I'm looking
around and it's still full of people but
it's like really quiet yeah almost to
the point where we're the only ones
talking and then in the corner of the
bar I see the sign in Japanese that says
buy yearly meet and drink Meetup for the
Deaf
and I noticed every single person in
this bar other than us is talking in
Sign Language oh wow and I'm like that's
why it's so quiet because literally no
one is talking and everyone is just
saying it that's awesome and and it's so
bad but like the first thing in my mind
that I thought of was well I hope we're
not being too loud
that's the only thing you don't have to
worry about now well it's like
immediately like oh [ __ ] oh wait no we
good but it was really cool because it's
like you know I I knew a couple of
people in school who were like deaf and
stuff like that but like I'd never seen
that many deaf people in a social
setting like a little on a bar right and
everyone's like signing to each other
and there are people on like uh video
calls to each other and they're signing
to each other and I'm like this is
really freaking cool but it's also
really weird because it's so packed and
yet it's so quiet yeah and you all you
hear is just like the rustle of like
clothes moving around and stuff if it's
not talking
um but so yeah that was a that was a
really interesting time I guess I guess
now you know if you come to Tokyo you go
to shibia there's a buy yearly meeting
for the deaf apparently so uh I like how
you got like the one day the buy the one
day the one day out of the two days yeah
where it's just a bunch of deaf people
who are like should we go drinking
yellow drinking yeah it was really cool
yeah this episode is sponsored by Ridge
guys are you tired of big bulky wallets
taking up precious pocket space well
thanks to Ridge that is a problem no
more Connor what are you holding there
this is the ridge walls look at that
minimalist design that's Sleek metal
plated wallet that fits nicely in that
front pocket of yours carbon fiber this
is a carbon fiber Ridge wallet and this
[ __ ] is Rock Solid oh my Lord I've had
previous wallets in the past that have
been really bulky and large and kind of
annoying to work through but the ridge
wallet is small sleek and simple and
it's so easy to get any of my cards best
of all fits in any pocket but did you
know guys Ridge doesn't just give you
these Sleek beautiful wallets as well
they also have the key case which comes
super handy in case I lose some keys or
stuff I know I'm just as shocked as you
are gone not to mention Ridge also has a
bunch of pocket knives as well as
backpacks they have the whole shebang so
if you want to go check out reach for
yourself and support the boys in the
process then make sure to go over to
reach.com trash taste but sure you
forgot to mention that using darling you
can get up to 40 percent off until
December 22nd so act fast back to the
video yeah I mean I've been out like a
like a bunch since coming back to Japan
and like I definitely noticed one one
thing I've noticed now is that before
now that because before everyone knew
you were living in the country right
every everyone knew you were living in
the country because the borders were
closed but now that the borders are open
I've seen like a total mentality change
right because now now before when I go
to a restaurant everyone's like oh you
know where'd you live how long have you
been living here now people are like
panicking because they're like is it a
is it a tourist or is it yeah
Japanese they're speaking to me back in
English now they're like all right well
that's a white guy yeah I think I went I
went to this restaurant the other day
with Sydney and they literally asked us
oh God uh are you visiting and we're
like no we live there and they're all
like oh it's a Japanese menu okay for
you because you know some places don't
have an English menu yeah we said yeah
we've lived here before Japanese menu
fine
um so we go sit down they give us the
English menu anyway even though we said
I've had that having me so many times
like the waitress comes up to me and
just like oh English is okay and I reply
back in Japanese you know being like no
no Japanese is fine yeah I live around
here and it's just like oh okay comes
back and she's like he's the Englishman
just in case I'm like [ __ ] I
just talked to you in Japanese I'm good
I can read it
getting our bags and this guy goes I'm
gonna bother you guys but I'm a big fan
appreciate that yeah no just like I'm
sure you you two have noticed as well
but just like oh bro yeah exponentially
just more people yeah I mean we did this
uh I did this irol stream with Chris and
Pete and uh yeah it was uh insane we had
so many more stream snipers oh yeah it
was insane I did I did notice an
interesting thing though where at least
with me uh I immediately know if someone
is a fan of like the anime man or if
someone is a fan of trash taste yeah
because I know they're a fan of trash
taste because they come up to me and
they go are you Joey
but if they're a fan of me they go are
you the anime man and then that's where
I'm like okay I know exactly like which
mode to switch to anyone want to talk
about and stuff because I had that exact
same experience like maybe 10 minutes
apart like one day because my parents
were visiting
um and you know I go recognized a bunch
because I was out and about and yeah
just like 10 minutes apart there was one
dude who was like are you the anime man
never heard of trash taste never heard
anything about trash [ __ ] just knows me
at the end ten minutes later American
dude stops me and goes yo Joey what's up
man I just missed out on the trash taste
toy and I'm like yeah it's it's really
interesting kind of like the the dynamic
between like the I guess the two fan
bases if that makes sense
um but yeah I mean I mean I can tell as
well because it's like the gig up or the
guns you know how do they refer to me
sometimes they just they just mistake me
for Joey which happens a lot there he
goes I love the other Asian guy in trash
taste I was like which one
which one were you referring to are you
talking about the full Asian guy
I was like all right
it's cool though because I felt like a
lot of the bars and restaurants feels
like they kind of returning to normal
almost yeah yeah it's like it's like
nice the world is healing there has
literally been like a switch I've
noticed that with like all these
restaurants and bars yeah yeah just it's
so much more alive now yeah and they're
so much more like down for foreigners to
come in yeah yeah it's crazy how night
and day it swapped it's like they're
actually prepared you know for you know
for more foreigners to come in well
because I'm sure as a business owner
you're probably just like frothing for
the foreigners to come back yeah I mean
like you know there's only so many times
I mean some of them are probably just
like oh God here they come again but
others are just like oh thank God we can
actually get customers in now yeah not
have to rely on the same three local
people that come back every week right
yeah it's been nice and now my favorite
thing now is seeing all the tick tocks
of like this crazy thing I found in
Japan it's like a really it's a really
like well-documented tourist thing yeah
yeah believe it it's like all right this
is the craziest idea this is the
craziest Cafe that I found in Shinjuku
and it's like all the same place
I'm not trying to be like talking dirty
it's just funny it's just funny I I find
it fun as well because I I get
recommended those tick tocks sometimes
as well where it's just like this is how
life in Japan works and it's like the
vending machines keep the [ __ ] drinks
I actually thought I saw that one
there's like eight amazing things that
made Japan so convenient yeah I remember
I saw one the other day which is like
this girl who clearly first time in
Japan and stuff like that and it was
like I want to take you guys to my
favorite local Ramen Shop that I think
is absolutely delicious it was a [ __ ]
eater no
[Applause]
in case you guys have been living under
a rock uh we just came back from the
trash taste tour in America oh it feels
so good yeah it feels good it's so good
uh too much America yeah
I I am America doubt yeah you know yeah
I wake up next to City I'm like why'd
you have to be American city God God
[ __ ] damn it I've had I've had enough
of this right now so we did 23 shows
around the entire US 41 days on the road
yeah there's uh yeah a long time went to
a lot of the most populated U.S states
obviously we didn't go to any of the
ones like Nebraska yeah Montana
sorry guys there's not much to do there
yeah like people there sorry Midwest
yeah but we had a lot of people from
those less populated states come to some
of the shows yeah which is cool read
some people Canada like drive down to
some of our like Northern shows and some
people came up from Mexico and stuff
like that as well people
flew in from Hawaii which is oh yeah
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] insane yeah
um that's crazy I mean yeah we had uh so
we had 23 shows we started from uh we
did one tester show in L.A then flew to
Minneapolis and got on the tour bus yeah
which was so much cooler than I think
any of us expected oh it was so cool I I
you know I thought I was kind of like
dreading the tour bus and you know we've
got a lot of questions about like what
is that I'm scared for the tour yeah
because I'm just like expecting yeah I'm
going to be leaving with this with these
guys and much of strangers for like 40
days I don't know how I feel about that
but it was actually like really really
nice really really comfortable and a lot
of fun as well yeah
um because it kind of felt like after
the road trip special which is now out
thankfully like I was I was dreading
that it was going to be 41 days of just
that experience
I'm literally gonna kill one of the boys
stuck in this space but like the tour
bus actually gave you like quite a lot
of space and quite a lot of like time to
do I think it definitely helped that the
majority of the traveling that happened
on the bus was happening while we were
asleep yeah so it was like traveling
yeah yeah yeah it was like Fast
traveling in RPG it's great because
people were asking us oh how's how's the
drive been how's the roads been and we
were like literally uh we we blink in
one place and we wake up in another yeah
the only roads I think we any of us saw
we were like the roads between
um I think Colorado and uh I guess Vegas
and all that stuff and a lot of Nevada
that was the only part I think we were
awake while we were traveling yeah and
even then it was like what an hour or
two in the morning yeah you don't
actually spend a lot of time on the bus
as you think so the normal day would be
you know you wake up you've arrived at
the new place you pretty much
immediately get off the bus so your bed
is like a capsule hotel but stacked and
there's 12 of you yeah
um and then you get off the bus shower
then you go get lunch then maybe you
wait around then do sound check at three
yeah you'd have to wait for like an hour
or two then we do the Q a before the
show at six yeah and we wait and then I
finished at seven wait one hour eight
and then we finish the show around 10 10
30. we maybe have a celebration on the
bus yeah we're drinking talking until
like two and then we go to bed and the
bus moves yeah that's kind of every
single day
that was basically our schedule uh our
life was just living on a bus or in a
green room and I'd like I don't know
about you guys like a lot of people were
like scared about would I get good sleep
on the bus I got [ __ ] fantastic sleep
I got better sleep on the bus than I did
in some hotels it was a nice role for me
some days I did some days I didn't it
was mainly like because I don't know
about you guys but I realized that
sleeping on a moving vessel while I
needed to pee was
I had to go pee like at least two three
times a night and normally normally I
don't ever have to pee when I'm sleeping
right right so this was like oh my God
I'm getting so stressed out that's how
old men feel I felt like I was I was
rapidly aging yeah um but some nights I
would get amazing sleep because the bus
kind of rocks you like like it's the
engine hum is so loud and also there's
AC in the sleeping like quarters yeah
yeah there's a giant AC unit that is so
loud and ventilation system yeah and
then so you cannot hear anything from
anyone else's bunk
um so it was surprised like because
because I remember the first time we got
on this bus and we saw how close of a
proximity all the beds were to each
other yeah I was like oh I don't think
there's gonna be any privacy like I'm
gonna be able to hear everyone [ __ ]
stuff nothing it's literally like in you
know when you fall asleep
it was perfect because even though the
AC in like the engine were really loud
they acted at like the perfect white
noise like if if you've ever like slept
with like a white noise like filter or
something in the background that's kind
of what it felt like where you couldn't
hear anyone snoring you can hear anyone
like rustle around or anything like that
you just heard a constant white noise
that was constant throughout the night
and then I sleep great on moving
vehicles I don't know about you guys but
when the bus I slept better when the bus
was in motion than when the bus was like
still although I must say our bus driver
did get a little wacky crazy at some of
the locations like there were some turns
where he did where I almost fell out he
only fell out yeah I had to like hold on
to being like Jesus [ __ ] crazy and
then obviously when you get into the
cities because you're stopping and
starting so much good traffic because
the highways are just you're going yeah
but the cities are stopping and starting
so you're like you know your body's sort
of coming out of the Sleep Cycle anyway
and then you're kind of like
a lot of the time yeah yeah so like to
explain this bus it was it we call it a
bus it's more like a coach you know what
I mean because when I say when I say bus
I think like double decker bus no it was
like a like a single Decker like coach
kind of thing and then you go into the
you go into the coach and then the first
thing you see is like this living room
area where you've got like a bunch of
you got like sofas on either side
there's a table in the kitchen and stuff
like that
um three TVs scattered all yeah three TV
scattered around permanently playing
[ __ ] SpongeBob or some [ __ ] whatever
was on American TV
um and then you go into the next room
and there are 12 bunk beds and there are
like three three stacks three layers
basically three layers so there's the
bottom layer there's the middle layer
and there's a top layer and according to
like most people you get the best sleep
on the middle layer right so me and
Connor chose the middle layer Joey chose
the top layer yeah which kind of scared
me because if you fall out of that bed
I mean you know I only chose the top
bunk because I'm a child at heart and I
was like oh yeah
but no like you know I I still got
really good sleep on the top it was fine
yeah yeah and then there's one extra
room in the back which was meant to be
for the talent room but that just that
just turned into let's just put all our
shits into this one room yeah and it was
like unusable yeah I guess in like a
normal tour yeah like the the talent
have their own like private quarters if
there's like one Talent apparently some
of the two buses have the like a room
that's like a bedroom as well oh okay
yeah yeah yeah right I mean that would
be cool
yeah and and you know for the most part
like we didn't really utilize that room
and it kind of just became like a
storage space just yeah because like
yeah I mean you know when when Aaron uh
who helped organize the store shout out
to Aaron by the way um you know was like
you know by the end of this tour these
guys who you think are strange just
right now who are going to be with you
on this bus they're going to end up
being like family yeah and like you know
I always thought when I heard that from
like multiple people uh you know who've
done tours before I just thought it was
like you know just some kind of like you
know it's not excuse type of thing but
you know just like I think that maybe
not everyone can relate to that type of
thing right but like I don't know I
don't know about you boys but like by
the end of the tour it was like a family
yeah right and we got really close to
the the stuff that we had and we were
always just like hanging out with them
in that front section and so we were
like we don't have to use this bathroom
let's just go hang out with everyone
else obviously you want to hang out
there real yeah they're always hanging
out with everyone this was a good time
so there's actually there was actually
more people than I thought they were
going to be living on the bus with us
like prior to the tour because we only
knew probably we were gonna have like
some Geeks uh Geeks plus staff members
and some people from the tour company
that we worked with I was thinking okay
that's gonna be like a manager someone
like stagehands I like didn't take into
account just how much staff is needed to
run a tour because there's like there's
like multiple merch people and there's
like managers and everything like that
and there's our staff as well on top of
that and you know there's the technical
people as well there were like so many
people on this tour bus with us and I
thought [ __ ] this is this is gonna be a
lot for 41 days but like it was such a
nice experience because luckily everyone
was chill and we'd pretty much got along
with everyone yeah
um and it was just I don't know you guys
you guys said it kind of felt like a
holiday in some cases yeah it did I I
definitely treat it as a holiday well
yeah because like we I normally work way
more than that so only doing like a
two-hour show and then having the rest
of the day where I can't really do
anything it's kind of like oh okay
because like you know there were some
days where like we had to stop by kind
of halfway between two places because uh
legally our bus driver could only drive
a certain amount of hours per day so
yeah there were some days where we would
stop buying just like the middle of
nowhere get a day hotel and then just
you know go and explore type of thing
and in my head I'm like okay before the
a toll I planned out these days of like
on the days that were at the hotel yeah
we could get like our own room and I
could like you know yeah
catch up to work and stuff like that but
then when it actually happened I was
like no I think I'd rather just go out
with everyone and like actually go see
this part of the country that yeah let's
be real probably not going to go back to
yeah like when am I ever gonna go back
to Biloxi Mississippi yeah you know so
[ __ ] I've had a great time there
actually I had a great [ __ ] time
there yeah yeah that was great I I
actually really enjoyed the days off
yeah definitely appreciate how much work
goes into doing these you know when you
go to a venue and you watch a show with
like with a thousand people or something
yeah maybe you realize just how many
moving Parts
you know a lot of people
um were like damn why don't they come
into my place or whatever it's like well
it's it's very [ __ ] difficult to
organize a tour yeah and it kind of
sucks a lot of people like why the US
um well the US isn't a very unique place
where it is actually like built for
tours yeah
um you know a lot of the time when
you're moving merch across borders and
that's how a lot of these shows I didn't
realize this either a lot of these
concerts only make like most of their
profits through the merch yeah like
ticket sales you don't actually get that
much money because a lot of the cot like
the venue's expensive everything else is
expensive all the staff like yeah you as
the like talent and the the kind of
agency or whatever you don't make much
money from the tickets yeah and the US
is in a prime position where you can
actually drive around all the same
country where all the same like rules
with selling merch it's all the laws
because I think we learned a lot just
from doing this us all because there
were a lot of complaints being like oh
they they've had they hate the entire
world because everyone just goes to the
us so we did one show in Canada and I
think like the only time we got like
negative feedback from our show yeah was
from that one show in Canada and that
was to do with there was like we we had
the show in Canada and uh we didn't
realize that there were different laws
in terms of bringing merch across the
border different law of hiring staff
members because all staff members need
to be hired locally and there was a lot
of logistical things that just weren't
within like our Radars when we sorted
out we didn't know that we didn't know
that but obviously the tool company knew
that but obviously still you know trying
to get like the merch shipments to
arrive on time I didn't realize this was
a problem but yeah that that's a whole
thing yeah that's that needs to be taken
care of so yeah a lot of the times
you're kind of hoping that all the
moving pieces should work sometimes they
don't and it's like what do we do yeah
yeah we ended up like shipping 12 boxes
of merch to our Canada show and one
arrived and then we had one day to get
as much merch made locally in Canada as
we could unfortunately it wasn't as much
merch as we had in our us shows but
that's kind of like the things that
people don't think about and don't know
about because you know when uh you know
if you do a tour in multiple countries
every country has their own laws every
country has their own taxes it's not
just getting people from One venue to
another you know it's uh what we're
trying to say is hate the game not the
player obviously it can be done these
people do it but it's just it's it's
harder it is our first tour the US makes
a lot of sense yeah this was also our
first tour as well so we had so many
things that I guess we just didn't know
until it happened I mean thankfully I'd
like to say that the tour was a massive
success I didn't see any negative
reviews no I'm so glad because like we
we one of the biggest things I was
worried about pre-tool was that we'd
start doing like shows and people would
like you know I've seen feedback before
of like you know people that have gone
on tours and you know I've seen the
feedback of just like oh it wasn't
really worth the money I spent all this
money seeing it just wasn't really worth
it and I'm like thankfully it felt like
everyone had a good time and we put on a
good show that we brought to like
different places and I was just like
after I think it was like after the
first show that I actually had like
faith in our show I guess because well
we had the outline of the show and we
didn't actually we'd never rehearsed and
we didn't really know how it was going
to go until the rehearsals which was two
days before yeah our actual show yeah
and like our show relied so much on like
crowd interaction and having a rehearsal
in front of like five people versus like
the thousand people that we had in our
actual show was like night and day in
terms of like Vibe and chemistry and
stuff like that
um so I was going through rehearsals I
was like I think we have a good show but
I'm not sure I think as well it was it
was tough for us because you know we do
stuff in front of a camera right yeah
and doing stuff in front of the camera
like this or like the videos that we do
personally is very different to putting
on a show on stage right and you know
some people will be like oh but you guys
are used to you know doing panels at
conventions and stuff like that it's a
very different feel yeah you know a
panel is a million times easier than
what what we were what we had to do on
on stage I was [ __ ] knackered after
everything oh yeah I I was I like it
drained me yeah so much and that and
that's because like we actually try to
make it a show rather than just make it
you know trash podcast on stage it's
really cool getting to see you guys like
from the first show like the 10th show
how much you guys quickly improved yeah
being on stage it was really [ __ ]
sick yeah it was awesome yeah I I think
by like the like halfway point we all
had like a rhythm and yeah yeah we knew
how to like bounce off each other what
worked well with the crowd but didn't
work so well with the crowds I also
noticed we had like just without even
discussing it necessarily we had like
certain jokes that we knew the kind of
Rhythm too yeah and like where to place
it and like because it was always you
know you you do the the show and then
you kind of noticed oh okay this joke
kind of hit maybe I can try it again in
the next show and then without thinking
like I knew exactly when say like Conor
o'gart were going to say specific jokes
and you exactly kind of the feeling
Rhythm to go with it right yeah yeah
like you know God would do like the one
piece's real thing at the beginning yeah
which always popped off right and I
always knew to sing can we get much
higher you know so it was just kind of
like it was is this weird thing of it
started off as very much like a an
impromptu ad-lib-filled script like you
know non-scripted show yeah but then I
feel by the end of it it kind of turned
into like almost a scripted show in a
weird way it was like like we had
segments that we didn't know what was
going to happen and segments that was
kind of like scripted yeah that we kind
of knew how to like transition between
segments and stuff like that definitely
and play off the audience and stuff like
that
um but like having said that you know I
I'd say that every show did have a lot
of like Variety in in them
um and we kind of did that by Design and
it was very very interesting to see how
what what the different vibe in each
city was we definitely learned a lot
about I guess like the diversity of
crowds in the U.S I I think what I what
I enjoyed most about the shows was
actually like our show was our way to
learn about that particular area and we
got we I learned a lot that you couldn't
just get by Googling yeah what are the
top five like uh what are the top top
five most famous things about this one
area right it was really really
interesting to see what certain states
and cities were really passionate about
yeah they weren't um yeah that was fun
because a lot of the times it was very
surprising yeah and you know a lot of
the times you've got questions because
we did a q a before every show uh and
people would always ask you know did the
tour change your opinion on the US at
all and I heard you always answer yes
and no yeah because yes some things did
change but it doubled down like 10 other
things oh God yeah we kept having like
an argument about like we were like is
the us more diverse than they they claim
or is it because right oh yeah I think
the US is more diverse than say the UK
compared to Australia I was like you're
full of [ __ ] like that's nice I I didn't
say that I I said it felt like like
going from uh West Coast to East Coast I
felt like going from like say LA to New
York to me felt more different than
going to London to Sydney I I and I
still believe
why is that offensive because it's like
not even close why not Australians are a
different breed of people yeah they're
like I don't think so I don't think so I
would understand the comparison between
say like Australia and New Zealand uh
that that's a little more understandable
but like Australia and England vote are
different we're different
yeah
I think I think culturally culturally
yeah you know I think Australians and
Brits have a lot in common oh of course
we have like a very similar sense of
humor we have a very similar I I I agree
there's comparisons there what do you
think of the differences then between
the west coast and the East Coast Vibes
um I think like I think the vibe in east
coast is like totally different from
west coast East Coast they like talk
faster they are much more direct with
the way they like speak and I I agree
with that you know like West Coast are
like way more chilled they're a bit more
flowery with their language and their
words whereas you know with East Coast
it's kind of like you know they talk way
faster and things move faster in the
east coast than the West Coast you know
I think I I you know I because when I
went to Sydney for example when I went
to Sydney
um I was like damn this kind of feels
like London with good weather you know I
I was looking you know that changes the
game though that that's that that's
everything the weather is everything no
no you no I remember the exact words you
said you were like wow you you know you
hung out in Sydney for like three days
and you were like this is like the UK
except if everyone was happy yeah I was
like yeah that's like going to other
European countries like it's like the UK
but different language it's like it's
like oh no no no no I I think I think I
think you know different countries in
Europe are [ __ ] totally different in
terms of like Vibes and cultures and
everything like that I was just saying I
think the UK and like UK and Australia
have a lot similar culturally I mean
you're comparing London and Sydney which
are two cities the UK is very diverse
throughout and you know you can't
compare Scotland to like London yeah
okay I would say there's a bigger
difference between like Dublin and
London you know yeah like Dublin feels
like a different country than yeah okay
okay but okay London let's say England
then let's say England because England
to me is London and then everywhere else
London has like have you gone to the
north I I have been to the North Korea
okay okay where have you got what's the
most how far north yeah how far north of
Liverpool
is Liverpool not North it's Livermore is
Northern come on North but it's not it's
not North North it's not Yorkshire it's
not [ __ ] because I've been to
Liverpool many times bro I've been to
Grimsby once it did not feel like
Liverpool right I don't know I I think
that I I think it's hard to you can
judge cities a lot easier especially
like London and Sydney because yeah well
Sydney was kind of built like London in
a sense yeah there are sections of
Sydney that look very similar to Saint
fine in London but I think if you're
comparing the culture of the country
like as Australia to the England it's
very different it's so different it's
night and day do you think so yeah why'd
you okay what do you think what do you
think is like so different about it then
because uh Jen joining okay this is now
yeah now you have to ask what is a
culture let's do this again well what
makes up the culture constitutes
so like are we talking just the people
are we talking because like you know if
you're talking how they have their own
dialect essentially they talk very
differently they're Australia has its
own language yeah yeah they have you
know they have uh its own native
population which is totally different as
well which plays an impact they don't
play the same Sports a lot of the times
as us they've AFL and they play some of
them like cricket and rugby but you know
they do play other sports yes yeah um
they have Sun that's a big one
we have good beaches that changes the
game quite frankly okay okay what okay
here's I think animals they're
completely different Landscapes
you can say that with a place like
America you know you go to [ __ ]
Florida you have [ __ ] Gators you go
to Colorado it's in its own thing but
that's the thing right it's still the
same country
there's native populations in America
obviously as well and it depends a lot I
don't know it feels weird because no
matter where you go right and no matter
how much local differences okay they
never quite lose that kind of
american-ness that they they always have
whereas like certain traits that I think
Americans often have right I think that
just never really so you always even
though you're in Seattle you're in
Florida it always feels like America is
that that feeling never really goes no
matter which at least from the mainland
I've never been to Hawaii or I mean
Hawaii they've been to Alaska I don't
know how that feels but yeah it always
still feels America like it can never
quite shake that that kind of The Vibes
that Americans have in a weird way yeah
I'm I mean I'm I'm saying I do think you
know there is some kind of like
american-ness in the feeling and stuff
like that but I'm saying like there is a
lot of like I go into different parts of
America it's like there was a lot of
like differences there was like there
was like some similarities but I've
never felt like such such a dichotomy of
like different mentalities and different
ways of thinking in the same country
before like well as I was saying the
reason I I brought up the UK and
Australia is that to me I it feels like
you know UK are like I'm gonna say
England okay because I'm mostly talking
about England yeah English people and
Australian people feel like they're cut
from the same cloth but they just have
different starting like parameters you
know but I feel like we're we're kind of
cut from the same cloth I you know you a
lot of English people get along well
with Australians I mean we're [ __ ]
same brain cell and [ __ ] like that even
though we grew up like halfway across
the world from each other you know what
I mean I feel like culturally we have
like the same sense of humor a lot of
the times we kind of think it's very
similar we have like you know we have
our different cultures that depend on
you know where we are in the world and
everything like that and like the
wildlife and the geography and all that
stuff but I feel like at its core we you
know we think a lot of the same ways
whereas in America you go to like
different stages like there is such a
big difference going from a red state to
a blue State it's like you you feel like
I agree with that and obviously a lot of
a lot of Americans will be watching this
they're like yo I don't want to be
[ __ ] grouped in with like Nebraska oh
yeah I don't want to be grouped in with
Florida yeah and that happens a lot so a
lot of Americans are always real really
feel patriotic a lot of the time about
their state or where they are yeah
um and I agree yeah there are a lot of
differences but again like I said it's
still feel like you never feel like
you've left America in a sense and like
I I very much feel like I'm not in the
UK when I'm when I'm in Australia when I
was there it definitely didn't feel like
it at all to me right I don't know I
know I was like walking around like
Sydney and I saw like pubs and I saw
like chippies and like chicken shops I
was like [ __ ] I feel like I'm in London
right now I kind of feel like I'm at
home right now I don't know again like I
said earlier it's hard to compare cities
right because the cities more often than
not like I I you get more Australian the
more you leave a city right yeah that's
true that's true I mean you know when I
went outside of London for the first
time you know like towards like small
country yeah yeah like you know Chris
took me to like Salisbury and like you
know other places like that I'm just
like this is definitely not like this is
just like as British as I get [ __ ]
gets but like you know I get yeah yeah
when it comes to the cities for sure but
like I don't know there's still I feel
just like fundamentally so much more of
a bigger difference just because of the
you know the the years that have passed
especially and the fact that
geographically we're so far apart but
like yeah even like you know I I get it
with like in America for example like
there is definitely more of a diversity
in terms of like the surface level with
the people like you know and not even
talking about like an accent wise right
like you know obviously the moment
someone opens their mouth for the most
part you know roughly whereabouts
they're from all right but like I still
feel like yeah it's kind of said like
they're still at the end of the day
regardless of if I was in Mississippi or
Seattle I'm like it's still it's
American they're still Americans and and
maybe it's because yeah and maybe it's
because there's this like what do you
think that thing is then I don't know I
think it says um you know I realized
from doing this tour and speaking to way
more Americans than I ever have in my
life is that Americans are like super
[ __ ] nice and they're really
hospitable hospitable for sure yeah
they're always really nice and then
occasionally they might just say
something or something gets brought up
and then you know like if for some
reason politics is ever mentioned they
say something like oh
okay yeah well we disagree on this yeah
well I keep my mouth shut I never ring
it up but I notice some people like you
cannot like okay between like super left
people and super right people initially
on the like if you're just talking you
cannot tell the difference between it's
just like with something gets said oh my
God does it come out very fast there's
like a rhythm to the conversation that I
think is very uniquely American and I
don't know exactly how I can describe it
yeah I don't know if it's because I'm
not American yeah I can't see it but
yeah everyone feels super nice super
welcoming and then if if for some reason
something's ever brought up that is
political even remotely so it flips to
the American that you see on the TV
right you know what I mean where you
have these these very strong opinionated
people who are very open and then you're
like ah okay this is the America you see
on the TV which is why in a way it kind
of made me appreciate America more in
the sense that I don't think it's all
doom and gloom where because I'm on TV
bro
they make America look god-awful yeah
they are doing you dirty and America
doesn't themself because they know
that's the that's what gets clicks yeah
of course um and so on on TV and from
movies and all the stuff you get the
impression that Americans are [ __ ]
insane and just to some extent in
Florida they are yeah yeah it is the
case but like I think most people in
America are super chill super nice
really awesome to talk to just don't
bring up politics yeah ever it's it's
funny because we actually funnily enough
we went you know everyone's just like oh
how many like how many more things you
have to [ __ ] on about America and we we
found a lot don't worry about that but
we also found things we liked about
America as well yeah because I I just
liked how you always knew where you
stood with an American you know because
I grew up in I grew up in British
culture where everything's behind like
10 layers of [ __ ] sarcasm or
something like that is someone being
passive aggressive or not you have to go
through like 10 lays to figure it out
like I get sent an email right a
business email he didn't he used regards
instead of kind regards is this is is he
like am I on it like a [ __ ] he's an
[ __ ] did I do something wrong to piss
him off or did he forget I don't know
with an American you always know where
you stand you know because they'll their
email will start with dear [ __ ]
corrects that they just tell you exactly
how they're feeling you don't have to
like hide behind like so much
bullshittery conversation is always nice
I always had a great time you know as
much as I hate tapping uh it was great
for getting rid of change that I didn't
want oh yeah I would just round out I'm
like this is awesome hold up wait this
is a scam uh yeah tipping was a joke at
times oh yeah so it is somewhat
convenient I understand why some
Americans are so attached to it but also
never ever let that [ __ ] leave America
please get that out of my country yeah
um uh and there's some other stuff that
was nice just people were always
Pleasant yeah
um but that was the thing right it's
like I don't know when it comes to like
the hospital boldness of like the
average American like for sure like I
think we all discovered it's like yeah
Americans for the most part very
welcoming you know when when they mean
to be welcoming and they're very
hospitable and they want to make sure
that you're having the best time that
you can in their country yeah right but
then at the same time I'm just like
is that the average American or is that
just the average trash taste fan yeah
you know that was a part of me where I'm
just like we spoke to a lot of people
outside of uh trash taste fans obviously
because we had a lot of days where we
were just not doing shows yeah and also
we were just talking to people normally
it was always a good time I know
definitely I don't think I had any bad
experiences
um but I'm white though so I don't know
I mean yeah I had a like I had got a bit
of an experience in Detroit
yeah I mean I I was like wait so when
you go to the tour you had a show in
Detroit and you know I've heard I had
heard about Detroit's reputation and
everything like that before yes uh so I
came out like Garnet so uh there was
this like anime shop there was like one
block away so I was like what's the
worst thing that could happen if I just
go to this in Detroit to go to an anime
shop no no no there was just one that
was just like a block away from our like
uh from venue from the venue and I was
like there's nothing we got like three
hours to kill yeah
um I was like well why not check it out
why not check out the anime shop just to
see what the the Detroit scene is like
right we walk out and I'm with my uh
with uh our producer at the time and I'm
walking around it's actually like a
really bougie area we had like really
nice coffee shops really nice it wasn't
as bad yeah from what I'd heard from
Detroit it sounds like yeah also yeah
like the delicious room was quite nice
yeah it was nice the streets were clean
and I was like damn this is not the
image image of Detroit that I thought it
was gonna be obviously I know there are
some areas that are obviously of course
but it was it was it was like a nice
boujee area and I remember talk like
turning to my producer being like wow
Detroit's not what I thought he was
going to be at it at all this is like a
really nice looking area this is really
bougie
um as soon as I finish the sentence I
walk around the corner
and then there's this guy walking up
towards us he sees me and he goes you
don't belong here get out and I was just
like uh is he talking to me I just I
don't know if he's talking to me maybe
it's just a crazy guy let's just go into
the store so we quickly like Shuffle
into like the store and as I opened the
door I just here in the corner of my ear
I'm talking to you boy get out now and
I'm like I'm just I'm just [ __ ] I'm
just gonna go in and just uh find solace
in the [ __ ] anime story I would have
been so scary yeah [ __ ] yeah
um and then I was like okay there's this
there's
there it is okay there it is not good
but that was the only time anything ever
happened right to any of us yeah I mean
I got I I definitely if there's one
thing I learned on this tour is how to
talk to homeless people and get out of
those situations because there were many
times throughout the tour where you know
after the show you know we were just
kind of like be hanging outside of the
bus you know just like talking and
chatting getting some fresh air and
stuff like that and then you know
usually it's like midnight or like one
in the morning yeah and you know because
we're for the most part parked in front
of a venue it's like you know right on
the side stream right yeah and of course
you know with uh most American towns
there's a lot of homeless people you
know walking around at night yeah and oh
my God I probably maybe con it was in
contact with like I want to say like 50
all together on this tour yeah homeless
people every single tour there was at
least one or two homelessness who walk
up to us and I used I used the diet I
was gonna say I I understand why this
has this technique now the first one in
in Minnesota dude walks up you know
asking for change or whatever it was I
don't know he was like slurring his
words and I just I hit him with the
sorry sorry man yeah anyway sorry he
just like grumbled and was just like oh
at least you're nice about it
and I was like oh my
oh my God yeah because I feel like okay
in terms of like americanness right
there is like an inbred skill in like
every Americanization
we drove through Alabama once and it
just changed me man it changed like
every American has this like ingrained
skill yeah to
um to de-escalate with homeless people
yes I'm I and I saw it like I remember
we were outside like the Texas venue and
like this this homeless guy comes up and
it was me you and Aaron uh and I
remember do you remember the homeless
guy I was like yo this there was Jay-Z
performing here and and and and like
Aaron was like a full-on conversation
with him and I'm thinking like he asked
like he asked us like for crack and
stuff like yeah and I was just like I I
I don't know what I'm doing I'm not
going to say [ __ ] can't now which is
completely silent yeah we were just
completely slowing and Aaron just like
dealt with it like a [ __ ] bro he was
just like nah sorry bro yeah sorry yeah
I mean I think a lot of the times they
get homes people get demonized too much
right at the end of the day they're the
[ __ ] people who you know for whatever
reason would like didn't life didn't go
their way yeah I think you know just
showing a bit of compassion they
appreciate that oh no of course like if
there's if there's one thing I've
learned it's like the the worst I guess
reaction you can get from a homeless
person is ignoring them yeah you know
because if you ignore them then that's
when they get pissed off right because
if you deal with it just like calmly and
just you know candidly just being sorry
man you're a human right no human wants
to feel ignored sorry man have a good
night just stuff like that they're good
yeah but like I I notice it's just like
very different in America versus like
the rest of the world for example
because oh yeah in most places in the
world you do ignore you know that's
that's kind of like that's kind of like
what you're taught to do right but in
America it's like when you you see like
a homeless person in America they're
like it's hard to describe they're very
much way more active and in your face
than compare it compared in comparison
to like other places in the world with
like homeless people I think it's harder
right you're harder to get by yeah yeah
they have a system that failed them yeah
yeah obviously one thing I think we all
noticed is that the homelessness in a
lot of the Cities was insane yeah
you know there's certain cities it was
like whoa California this is bad yeah
yeah I mean obviously because West Coast
it's a lot warmer all year round so a
lot of times people can live there yeah
um so that makes a lot of sense but man
you just you feel for them man you know
the system in America the way it's built
is not fair I I remember though uh Sarah
our VIP manager was just blown away by
the fact that it's like wait homeless
people don't just talk to you in Japan
it's like it's like what do they do and
I'm like you do you barely see them yeah
maybe in like Shibu or Shinjuku you
might see them but everywhere else dude
they're not there she's like where are
they all
and she just couldn't believe me when I
said like yeah homeless like I don't
have to deal with homeless people in
Japan yeah they just don't come up to
you and she just couldn't believe she's
like what what do you mean what do you
mean you don't have to deal with them
like as in the not there and I'm like
yeah I mean I think in Japan obviously
talking about homelessness there's a lot
of um obviously how you become homeless
and the systems that make you homeless
in a sense yeah are very I think
impactful on then how as a population
maybe they behave or what they need to
do yeah Mary you've got to be ruthless
to get by oh yeah you know in Japan I
think there's there's more options that
you have and the the reason why I think
homelessness is hard to get out of in
Japan is it's so expensive to get a
place and if you don't have the correct
documentation it's impossible oh yeah to
get it sorted yeah and then a lot of
homeless people in Japan there I mean
there's some that you see sleeping on
the street but a lot of them how much
people in Japan live in manga cafes or
live in those hotels that are one night
and they're they're like 30 or something
really cheap oh they live like along the
river under them yeah yeah a lot of the
times they don't you know it's it's like
it's an entirely different system
because of the whole the whole way that
they become homeless and and the
barriers stopping them from getting out
of homelessness are different yeah and
so I you know it's very telling of the
system and what's in place yeah yeah
that's why in Japan it's different yeah
because I think it's just something that
if it's like your first time in America
uh because like my parents like came to
America for the first time this year as
well uh and it it shocked them because
they they'd never seen this kind of like
this you know this kind of like system
with uh with homeless people yeah you
know it's it's something that every
American knows how to deal with but if
you come outside from like come from the
outside to see what is the situation in
America it's just like very very like
shocking I remember the first time I
visited America and a homeless dude
talked to me I was like this is where I
die yeah I could see the [ __ ] HP
oh my God I'm gonna have to fight my way
through this situation you know it's
very intimidating it is you've never
been experienced the US yeah especially
if you come from [ __ ] Japan you know
it's scary [ __ ] I'm sure yeah it's
terrifying yeah it's depressing as well
I hate seeing it online with people like
demonize homeless people and they're
like man that they're the [ __ ] worst
or it's their fault their homeless yeah
maybe sometimes that is the case but I
feel like just labeling them as lazy or
whatever is is so not helpful to the
situation and uh it's so frustrating
yeah it's it's their fault if they're
homeless just buy a home yes right stop
buying Starbucks laughing that [ __ ] that
[ __ ] drives me on the wall actually
actually yeah there was one situation I
think if we were in uh Nashville uh
Tennessee there was a there was a
homeless dude that came up to me he was
a really nice guy yeah and just like I
actually had like a really nice
conversation with him and you know at
the end of it all like I I just gave him
like five bucks because I'm just like
you know what you're not actually all
that crazy I actually had a great
conversation with you you're respectable
about it whatever yeah that's fine so
yeah take my money but like you know if
you're gonna come up to me and be rude
and [ __ ] about it then like don't expect
change you know that's not how you do
this [ __ ] you know no I I I I saw one it
was actually in Colorado actually
um you know there was there was a
homeless person uh who was asking for
money uh and you know a common response
was obviously sorry don't have any money
on me yeah uh you know I've only got a
card and he was [ __ ] prepared man he
he whips out this like one-on-one of
this like you do you know the square
[ __ ] yeah
it was like don't worry you can tip me
if you want I'm like yo he's [ __ ]
hustling man yo yo marvelous dudes in
the 21st century holy [ __ ]
on his phone he's like I got PayPal I
was like no [ __ ] shocked me man I was
like holy [ __ ] I respect that I'm taught
in many ways about it because I I also
like you mentioned like that one of them
was nice and some of them aren't nice
yeah well I don't know in a weird way
it's like man the government should
[ __ ] help them why do I have to
decide which one is a good Court Jester
and which one amused me the most yeah
yeah give money out like a king giving
it to a peasant like I'm like just
[ __ ] help these people stop stop
doing wasting all this money on other
[ __ ] but I guess they say a lot of
people don't want to don't want to pay
yeah and also the problem's going on so
long now that there's no there's no
simple solution so ingrained and yeah
accept it it's just become a cycle now
unfortunately yeah yeah I mean I've
currently the system's broken and uh I'm
not well informed enough to
unfortunately not to fix it yeah God's
stepping in guys guys
here's how you deal with it well okay
just give them houses it's also oh you
want to preface that obviously America
has a bad one but like the UK and Europe
is also not not great at all oh
Australia has tons of homes yeah yeah
for sure yeah I mean house prices are
[ __ ] insane yeah all of Europe and
Australia and America right now and you
know
it's hard to change the rules when the
dudes in top have uh have benefits yeah
in making sure the house prices stay
high yeah yeah
but like what okay so we went across
like how many states do we go in America
again I'm in a cross or like a
drive-through or like stopped in
Stockton yeah like 30 maybe 40 35. what
was that no not that many no maybe 30
30. I'd say yeah 25 to 30. yeah because
it was weird because I was like talking
to Sydney I was like I think I've been
to more States than you have now yeah
how [ __ ] well we've probably traveled
more of the US than most people yeah
yeah I I actually downloaded an app
which is like you can mark off like
which states you've been to in the US
I've been to exactly 25 States like 50
of the US yeah and I'm like that's more
than most Americans I'm like that's
pretty cool but obviously we only spent
a day there so it's like yeah I don't
count the ones we drove yeah yeah I
think like a day is enough to get like a
Vibe no I agree but not enough to like
know everything about the place but no
okay it was like enough for me to get a
Vibe about where I would where would
like possibly like to go back in the
future maybe yes top three places in the
US we went to go
um on this Tour on this tour okay
first place is easy for me Nashville
Tennessee
that would be in my top three for sure
like Nashville was super weird for me
because if you're not from the US you no
one really like knows about it there's
no some musical people are from there
yeah you just know if some new musical
people know about it uh are from there
sorry but like no one really like talks
about Nashville but it was like one of
the most active and happening cities we
went to on our tour I think uh because
there's this strip on Nashville uh and I
went it's called the strip it's called
The Strip it was like I think it's like
their Broadway or something like that
um and I went there on a Tuesday at 3
P.M and it felt like I just walked into
a music festival there's this strip in
Nashville that is like playing that has
live music in every bar 24 7. that's
pretty cool yeah it's [ __ ] insane
um and also like the city was like very
chill it's like in the South as well so
you get like Southern Hospitality which
I was like one thing I discovered him
was good the chicken there was awesome
and and and it was only one of uh four
cities that voted bone and chicken as
Superior so what isn't there to like
about Nashville Tennessee [ __ ]
awesome City I like natural good chicken
all right so what's number two and three
then gone number two
is it is it just on this tour just on
this tour just on the stool yeah that
you discovered okay it's it's I don't
know if it's gonna be a cop-out but I
already enjoyed Toronto Canada as well
the only Canadians that we went to no I
really really enjoy Toronto and I'm
already like planning to go back they
would sit here actually I like Toronto
too but I'm not including it on the list
yeah are you know what you said on this
talk we technically went there on this
tour where's number it was number three
then number three
I'll have to think about it
well for me it's like in no particular
order Nashville Tennessee was sick as
[ __ ] yeah uh I really like Denver
Colorado Okay um just because like it
kind of has like it weirdly reminded me
a lot of Melbourne in the sense that
it's like especially like in Denver like
in the city everything is like you know
it's it's built up and it's compact but
like there's a lot of things to do in a
really small vicinity like you could
walk Denver if you wanted to and like
explore it and stuff like that it was
really [ __ ] dope
um and then I really like Seattle I was
going to say Seattle is sick as [ __ ]
because I I I remember going there I
loved like I love the culture of Seattle
yeah it's kind of like it's it's kind of
like a good mix
um it's like a good mix of like West
Coast yeah without like but I think like
felt like their own flavor than say San
Fran and La yeah the we went down to
those uh like famous uh markets yeah
yeah
um and and like I don't know about you
guys but like it gave me like a weirdly
European Vibe yeah yeah like in like a
weird way like it was clearly still like
American right but like the markets
themselves and like kind of the
atmosphere and the vibe of just that
little area like near the water was very
European I'm like this is cool
I will say though I I probably wouldn't
include Seattle on the list because I've
been to Seattle several times before
because I have family there
um I really really like the city but we
went when we went there weather was
perfect yeah weather was perfect all
right I've been to Seattle before and it
was raining basically every day and it
was rain I [ __ ] despise rain okay
I don't want the rain oh another place I
actually quite enjoyed which I've been
to before but this time around I had a
really really fun time was uh Chicago
yeah I was gonna say so my top three in
no particular order Chicago's probably
on there so it was fun I hate to say
this to piss off New York people but
it's like New York it better
um I know that's gonna that's gonna
trigger so many more people
um it kind of had like all the cool
aspects of New York uh at least at least
the central part yeah I didn't go to the
scary part yeah yeah
um but the the town like the downtown
and the center of it was amazing I
thought sick and the food was awesome
yeah
um except people kept trying to sell me
drugs that kind of sucked oh yeah of
course Chicago Seattle for sure yeah
that was [ __ ] awesome that's such a
good time yeah Seattle there's a city is
so cool yeah and where it's laid out is
awesome yeah a really really walkable
again it reminds me of Melbourne great
food I had awesome [ __ ] food Seattle
with the seafood
had king crab so good yeah so good
actually oh go for it and then third
City that's a tough one to put on I'd
say I actually really enjoyed Austin
Yeah Austin Austin was right I I was
like because I you know I it's weird
actually like I I noticed that if I like
my tier list of like American cities we
went to a lot of like the top tier ones
are the ones that were easier easy to
scoot around in I noticed I noticed a
correlation of ease of like ease of
ability to scoot around in with the
e-scooters and my likability of that
City I will show I really I've been
there before but I really like
Minneapolis I wish we got more time
there yeah yeah Minneapolis is like a
Vibe we get this really cool Diner yeah
I forgot what it was called owls owls
breakfast that's so [ __ ] good and
that vibe in that Diner was so fun
everyone the staff they were sick yeah I
was asking questions they were like so
you really eat beans on toast yes yes we
do you can't get it here though yeah I
am I I don't want it here don't want it
yeah it was so good I love Minneapolis
which of course yeah I really like this
is fun I really like the Midwest Midwest
Shame about your Winters though as well
oh
my God and of course it was I we had to
be there on my [ __ ] boat
yeah I swear to God it felt like a cod
zombie I felt like we were going to get
points if I brought it up Windows like
there was no one no one in Cleveland
Ohio yeah I I've been told that Columbus
Ohio was much better and it was much
more lively but Cleveland shocked yeah
yeah because I remember I remember when
we woke up for our Ohio show and uh you
know sometimes we have to stop for gas
or something uh in Midway from like you
know driving to each City I wake up I
look out the window and I turn to one of
the staff members I'm like so when are
we going to the venue
and he points to like this empty parking
lot and he was like this is the venue we
are here now and I was just like what
yeah it was wrong it was wrong one thing
we learned from this tour about America
is that for some reason everyone is hey
so higher for some reason uh even Ohio
hates Ohio no one likes no one likes
Ohio yeah yeah we we had uh we had one
of the questions in our live show was
like what is the one stage you don't
want to be transported or Isa guide to
and uh out of 23 shows 21 states voted
Ohio as like the worst state in America
including Ohio including Ohio and I'm
like what the [ __ ] yeah
it was only San Francisco and Portland
and they voted at number two yeah so you
know it's not much better weird how the
US collectively came together to hate
Ohio yeah because like I think like
everyone's Minds you know outside out of
America it's like the worst state is
Florida right because you just hear
about it so much and it's so
sensationalized with like Florida man
stuff like that but I guess like the the
the truth the the True Villain at the
end of it all the secret villain not the
like once you defeat Florida who's the
secret boss at the end it's Ohio baby
after the credits roll it's a final boss
you have to fight and that's Ohio yeah
so that was interesting but uh you know
yeah after our stop in Cleveland I'm
like yeah you know what don't blame him
it's pretty bad I think I would have
enjoyed um Colorado more if I didn't
[ __ ] up when I got there why what
happened oh yeah so yeah so throughout
this entire uh tour we had a lot of like
spare hours like it'll be an hour here
and out there yeah and I would just play
TFT uh Team fight time Conor was
addicted I would just play it because it
was a lot of the times we would have
like two hours free and you can't really
leave the venue yeah you can't really do
anything so I'm like okay I'll just play
two games of TFT so I was playing Team
fight tactics I found of like bronze and
I finished the tour like diamond two it
was like a madman and uh I was just
playing a lot of games and I'm enjoying
it whatever and uh in Colorado
um we got to the hotel I had like an
hour an hour and a half before I was
gonna go and meet up with gone so I was
like yeah okay I'll uh I'll I'll run the
bathtub and I'll play a game right oh
yeah
so so I I go to the bathtub and I you
know because a lot of the times I'm like
you know you have to run the bath and it
takes forever to fill yeah so I run the
bath and then I go to play this TFT game
I'm playing it and bear in mind I've
been trying to get diamond for a while
right and this is my Diamond promo game
right so if I win this if I get top four
I get I get diamonds what a price to pay
yeah so so I'm I'm playing this game
right it's going well and I'm I'm
literally there's five of us left so I
need to get fourth to place and I'm
doing it and I'm finally I'm in the line
I'm in the the round against the me and
me Fifth and fourth we're on like one
health bar each so if whichever one of
us wins this fight we we win yeah and so
I'm playing it right and I I just about
just about beat this guy and I finished
fourth and I get my [ __ ] 10 points
and I'm [ __ ] happy hopping off I'm
like [ __ ] yes yes and then on the door
here
uh oh okay and so I get up off the bed
and as I put my foot down on the carpet
I hear like a like a Squish and it's not
like a like a light little squish it's a
deep squish like water envelops my foot
yeah oh oh [ __ ] and I see because the
beds here and the hallway goes around
like this and I just see wet going all
the way around right right to the door
I'm like what the [ __ ] so I run in the
bathtub I turn it off and prior to this
I checked that the bathtub had like the
drains yeah so that it like overflowed
like things so it wouldn't overflow and
it had them but clearly they weren't
[ __ ] work right so and then I quickly
pulled the plug realized the plug
doesn't basically work like it doesn't
unplug you have to prop something in
there to keep it up right yeah it's like
one of those ones stuck in yeah and so
it won't prop up and I'm trying
everything I'm trying to [ __ ] empty
it you know I'm like hearing yeah on my
door and I'm like [ __ ] okay so I I empty
this bathtub or try to and it's emptying
so slowly yeah yeah um and I opened the
door and I just see that from my hallway
I can just see a wet patch going around
bear in mind this is 30 minutes of a
bathtub yeah it did this much damage
right so I'm like oh [ __ ] I'm sorry and
I'm thinking [ __ ] I can't say I was
playing League of Legends
I can't say that's the reason why this
happened uh so she's like what happened
I'm like I I ran a bathtub and I fell
asleep I'm so sorry I've been really
tired yeah and she was like oh okay okay
um I'm gonna go and call the engineers
so I wait in this damp room I'm like
shoveling the water because the the
bathroom's tiled yeah so I'm just
shoveling the water into the sink yeah
trying to get rid of all this water in
the bathroom right yeah I managed to get
rid of most of it
um again I don't know how on Earth
there's this much capacity this is much
volume of water that was generating for
30 minutes it's insane yeah um and then
the engineers come one of them's like
super Southern Sound he goes golly this
is crazy and he goes I'm like I'm like
yeah man I I'm so sorry what the heck
happened here yeah I was like yeah I
fell asleep I ran the bathtub and he's
like all right well they're telling me
they're like yeah just go down to the
front desk and uh tell them that you you
flooded your room and you're right yeah
and I was like [ __ ] how is this gonna
[ __ ] cost me bro this is gonna cost
me so so much [ __ ] money so
I go down and I'm like hey yeah I'm the
guy who flooded this room can I have a
new room like yeah yeah sure no worries
all right oh like remember like berate
right yeah she I'm like I'm sorry sorry
this is complete action I mean to do
this she's like oh no no don't worry
yesterday somebody flushed their toilet
all the [ __ ] went to the floor below and
I was like I was like
what like yeah it's an old building this
[ __ ] happens all the time I'm like what
okay they seem really chill about it
they were like they made me feel like I
did nothing I'm gonna flood another
hotel room why are you flooding your
hotel room amateur I'm gonna load
another game of League of Legends this
is awesome
um you know and so I I get the keys I go
to the new room and I wanted I wanted to
take a bath death even though I wasn't
scared I was determined and it was like
some Cosmic intervention had come
because there wasn't even a plug so I
couldn't even take it back they
purposely put you in their room to be
like
I was like he ain't taking a bath man
bad things happen I brought in my hand I
was like I wonder if this should have
been a problem that kept happening where
like because none of the Overflow things
worked yeah before they were like just
don't like to have bats
am I gross for wanting to take a bath in
a U.S Hotel absolutely [ __ ] lutely
but I just wanted to soak in it I just
wanted to relax yeah and so I I I was
like no I'm taking a bath and I got one
of the hand towels and I clogged it and
blocked the drain so I could have a bath
just enough so the water wouldn't leave
yeah and then when I was done pulled it
all out had my bath successful was
should I have been deterred from
plugging the bath after flooding one
room absolutely yes no you didn't flood
one room you flooded three rooms right
so yeah so so it was it was interesting
because um I got a message from Mylene
who obviously David must have told so
I'm one of the managers are told and
then I kept hearing Chinese Whispers
versions of my own story and then they
were like I heard he broke the whole
hotel it was like no I heard he flooded
four floors I'm like no I heard four
people
what actually happened was not that you
guys ever heard an alternative story is
that I FL I not flooded the room next to
me got really [ __ ] wet and the room
below me got really wet so three rooms
in total my room the room next to me
[Music]
guys I don't flood four floors I didn't
flooded three rooms guys four floors is
way more dramatic come on that's like
the entire Foundation is [ __ ] right so
um
the room next door was available by the
end of the day they just had to blow dry
the floor with this giant [ __ ] thing
because like because what happened was
is later about an hour later after this
all happened I went back to look at the
scene of the crime yeah because I wanted
to see the damage right
was it was all dry right by an hour an
hour and a half later because I had this
giant [ __ ] heat thing yeah which
clearly this has happened before oh yeah
one of these things it was it was drying
the carpet and the carpet was all dry
yeah and I was like oh all right and
then and then I I was like what's the
what's the damage now like well if
there's anything we'll let you know yeah
and uh they and so I heard back from
them yet no oh [ __ ] no so I still
haven't had to pay anything yeah he's
just like I'm in Japan now
bro I was I was about to fight like I
was about to become Better Call Saul
your honor the bathtub should have
drained there was a drain and it wasn't
working clearly an engineering yeah
clearly a flaw on the design of this
bathtub and this was an accident waiting
to happen certainly okay hold on no I
was about to say the cherry on top of
this entire [ __ ] cake is just the fact
that this happened because you're
playing [ __ ] sleep
you can't make that [ __ ] I think I think
my favorite reaction because I was like
I was actually like in a bar because we
were ironically enough worlds like 2022
was going on and we were like I was like
there was a game going on I was like
Connor you want to come to this bar and
watch some league with me and so our
tour manager was going to join us as
well
um and I'd heard that because the room
was booked under her name yeah she had
heard that uh that's you know one of her
talents that she was taking care of had
fell asleep in the bathroom so then they
again this kept the story kept changing
apparently I'd fallen asleep in the
bathtub
so she was like panicking being like Oh
my God Connor you okay you hurt are you
like oh yeah did anything happen and he
was like yeah I was uh no no no she goes
oh my God what happened to you okay and
I just said back I'm like yeah what's up
like nothing happened
yeah I'm fine I was uh playing League of
Legends I was like she was like I
already felt even better man I texted
her I'm like yeah so I was actually
playing League of Legends and I lied
because I didn't want to seem like I was
an absolute [ __ ] idiot
but that's what happens you know you
grab you grab the dog in the League of
Legends yeah you took an immediately
they're very kind about it again all the
hotel staff was super chill about it and
I really appreciate I just want to know
what kind of [ __ ] happens on a daily
basis in that hotel if this is something
that's like yeah whatever I'm minor
inconvenience I'm sure the weirdest
[ __ ] [ __ ] goes down hotels
every Hotel manager has like a [ __ ]
story oh bro [ __ ] that has gone down in
a hotel yeah but that was fun yeah um
yeah and then I didn't really have any
other funny insane stories other than
the time that I went to the gym with
Aaron and [ __ ] died nearly that was
funny oh yes and you uh threw up yeah so
so I don't know what it is
um I I I can so I obviously I have
exercised a fair amount yeah but
obviously on the tour riding exercise in
like three weeks right and um I have
this thing that I don't know when to
stop
when my my body is telling me to stop
I'm like yeah but that's just that's
just that's just like baby [ __ ] I'll
just keep running yeah and then I always
regret it because I realize I've ran
past a certain point of like no return
where my body will now not feel good and
I will actually have like [ __ ] it my
body out right right so
I I we started uh Aaron was like let's
go to the gym I really want to go to the
gym and I okay so how this all came
about is the night before I was like
let's go gym Aaron but we were kind of
having like a few drinks and stuff and I
woke up the next day and I didn't really
want to go to the gym anymore and so I
showered and I came out of this room and
in the corner Aaron was just sitting
there on the couch and he's like so
you've shout huh
not going to the gym anymore and I was
like no no I'm still going I just want
to shout out for the gym
trying to freshen up a little bit you
know what's what assuming all right
let's go to the gym right now
begrudgingly getting my stuff out of the
bus to go to the gym so you go to the
Gold's Gym and Aaron's like what do you
want to do and I was like well I
normally do cardio then I normally do
like muscle exercises and he's like yeah
sure whatever so I think he was like all
right let's do cardio but let's do it
how I used to do it when I was prepping
for Crater Clash yeah okay so we're
doing basically boxing uh yeah and this
[ __ ] I knew it was going to be brutal
but I was like well I can't be a little
I mean I just like I did my first one of
my first few times hanging out with that
I don't know yeah I don't like let him
down and obviously I I my cardio
exercise is definitely different from
this he wanted to do a like a 15 20
incline uh at uh like a six miles per
hour Pace uh which isn't crazy but it's
pretty tough God if you haven't done it
and you haven't been practicing this
type of workout that's tough yeah so
we're running this for about uh I want
to say about five minutes and I'm I'm
struggling and he's like all right we
can stop and I'm like [ __ ] okay good
good he's like we'll do one more round
after this I'm like okay [ __ ] I will do
one more round [ __ ] [ __ ] I normally do
cardio and I probably go like you know
I'll do like around like 3K nothing
crazy just kind of like get the cardio
burn a few calories right yeah get the
fitness just there and then I'll go on
to wait and spend more time doing that
so this is just like I'm not prepared
for this
so we start doing the other one and
about halfway through this like five
minute incline thing I can feel my body
being at the point where it's like you
gotta stop or we are going to have
consequences yeah yeah but I'm like no
no we'll keep going we'll keep going so
keep going for some reason I can I can
keep going even when my body's begging
me not to and I don't know why I've
always had this problem from a kid where
I like whatever my internal limit is I'm
just like no no it's fine and I keep
pushing myself and this might never
matter yeah yeah this used to happen a
lot in like races where in school if we
were doing like a big race for like the
end of year racing I would do the whole
race and right at the end I would just
throw up yeah because I would just keep
going right yeah and this happened a few
times and I haven't done it in a few
years
um it's normally when I haven't trained
enough yeah so I go and I do it and I
feel awful and so we start doing some
weights and I do one we do a whole set
of like chests it's fine but something
feel a bit more rough
come on I can keep this down I can keep
this down I'm not going to throw up I
just felt queasy and I didn't feel good
and we started doing uh triceps and I
just I hit this wall where I was like I
don't feel good so I go I'm like Aaron
I'm gonna go to this world real quick
and so I just sit in the toilet you know
you sit in the toilet for five minutes
yeah like Shinji like yeah yeah just
collecting your thoughts yeah I'm just
trying not to throw up yeah and so I'm
like okay I think I got to the point
where I don't feel great but I think I
can continue yeah
so I really wanted to continue the
workout because we you know we were like
I was having bonding yeah yeah I was
having a good time and he's he's super
[ __ ] nice right yeah you know Aaron
if you watch this you're such a [ __ ]
nice guy and I just thought I just
wanted to not be a weirdo what's a trash
day so I I you know then we go back and
I do just one more like rep yeah and
then I was like tell her I'm like Aaron
yeah I'm gonna I don't feel so good I'm
gonna go to the toilet real quick and I
go and I just I'm just like it's like
[ __ ] Team America on this toilet for
a good three four minutes I'm trying to
rinse my mouth I don't have toothpaste
so my mouth feels gross but I'm like
rinsing my mouth out I'm like oh God and
I'm like Aaron I'm like I feel much
better now like dude I feel you know
when you throw up and you feel way
better but obviously like your stomach
still hurts from throwing up yeah right
but I felt fine like I felt good to go
some AB training yeah so we continued
the workout so normally the way I do it
and it's this is just a me thing I know
there's whatever way you want to do it
normally what I'll do is I'll do cardio
and then I'll do four sets you know um
so four four different workouts and I'll
do 10 10 sets two sets of 10 reps four
sets is that how it is
um that's how I normally do it and then
so we finish these four and then he's
like all right time to do core workouts
and I'm like oh no I don't think he
realized I threw up I I thought I made
it clear that I did but I don't think he
realized he's just like breathing his
face no no no no no so so luckily it
didn't smell too bad because I I could
feel it in your mouth you feel like it's
staying here it wasn't too bad luckily I
don't know wow and so we're doing core
it was just stomach right and so so
we're doing these workouts and I'm like
ah and he's like damn you get that burn
going I'm like this is not the burn I
wanted [ __ ] so are you supposed to feel
it from the inside yeah
I somehow get through this core I am
[ __ ] because I came back to you guys
and I was like
it goes Aaron didn't realize I'd thrown
out but I told the other guys like I
just [ __ ] threw up felt awful yeah
and then after he's like you threw up
that's awesome
he said I didn't know that yeah I was
like y'all saw him I was like I thought
he just took a [ __ ] man I thought he
took a [ __ ] and just felt better that's
my mid workout
at least I'm happy I got a workout done
I I try my best to do some workouts and
the Tour Total I only got two workouts
done over yeah two like a month and a
half but but nothing but you know what
is impressive about that and and the
entire tour for that matter is that we
all found out not too long ago somehow
God forbid maybe some divine
intervention came in we all lost weight
yeah
for sure I call it the hamburger diet
you know I would say it's a new diet
it's like keto get the [ __ ] out of here
I ate everything on the food chart yeah
yeah I had like a family pack of Doritos
every night yeah every night oh because
like every place we'd go to right ever I
swear to God every [ __ ] place so we
tried to like go to as many like local
chains local try all the local foods
every like American food is either
burgers or meats or meat and cheese or
fried stuff yeah there's there's nothing
that's hot dogs pizzas hot dogs just
like the the most unhealthy food you can
imagine and at the beginning I was like
yeah I'm let's let's do this I'm
traveling around America let's try all
the local [ __ ] dishes for sure by the
like end of the tour when when we'd like
talk to like the fans and they'd be like
yo have you tried this burger joint I'm
like I'm getting to the point where
[ __ ] all Burgers taste the same now
I'm like please do not recommend me a
burger joint right now I will literally
throw up okay oh [ __ ] man I had so many
hot dogs as well I was trying to try
every like local hot dog style yeah yeah
and some of them are god tier dude yeah
I like the Chicago Detroit and uh DC hot
dogs it's so good yeah but I will say
there's a yeah at least there's a lot of
overrated things I think the most
overrated thing in America is chicken
waffles I think it's so overrated it's
not that good yeah I mean like we I had
chicken and waffles a couple of times um
we had it in North Carolina and North
Carolina I had it in Mississippi as well
I I had chicken and waffle and my body
has never been more concerned oh bro it
felt like I was dying it was it was like
sensory over I was just like am I having
breakfast lunch or dessert I'm so like
my body is yes my body was just like
what is go why why you have why am I
having breakfast lunch and dessert at
the same time this is not a taste
profile I am like I I will like it all I
don't know yeah I love chicken tenders
what what is chicken waffles it's uh
exactly exactly what you think it is a
waffle with chicken Fried Chicken Fried
Chicken Fried Chicken on top of the
waffles with cereal with syrup oh my God
yeah yes like soccer stations
take the chicken not the one it's yeah
it was insane and like you know it's
cool as like a novelty thing right being
like you know this is something that is
like very American and whatever and the
first time I had it I was like okay yeah
this is actually kind of bomb you know
it's pretty good but holy [ __ ] I feel
like I just put on like 17 pounds from
this meal I love chicken tenders so much
American chicken tenders are like next
level it is they're so good it's so
every like we had a we had like chicken
tenders at the Nashville hot chicken
places I can't remember which one it was
also the one that like Charlie got us in
Tampa as well yeah
it's dude
I'm about to go off I'm about to go
chicken tenders are so [ __ ] good dude
American I I have I have a message for
Americans okay uh because I understand
now why these two think all chicken
taste the same why is that because every
time you [ __ ] eat chicken you only
eat chicken dendies I'm like there is
more to chicken Americans than [ __ ]
chicken tenders so [ __ ] tired of
chicken tenders I'm like there is you
guys don't seem to eat any thing like
every time we got like a recommendation
for a chicken joint you know people were
like yo like Raising Canes is like so
much better and some people like yo
Chick-fil-A so much better I'm like it's
all you're just eating chicken tenders
they don't do 10. it's either ten
dollars nuggets I'm like I'm like it's a
contend he's a God too man
I I could I could eat chicken tendys
every single day oh 100 every single day
so far poly mustard those sauces they
had bro not stupid it just it just like
annoyed me to no ends like every time
we'd go to a chicken place what are we
having chicken tendies I'm like do you
not have wings do you not have the
thighs do you not have the [ __ ] like
you don't have the legs it's just like
there's so much to a chicken and every
time it was like they were like yo
Raising Cane's God's here this is so
much better than the other place and I'm
like it's all the [ __ ] same because
all you're really judging is the sauce
you're not even judging the [ __ ]
chicken
quality was good it was good quality it
was it's like you know I think like most
of the most of the chicken places we
went to the chicken quality was kind of
the same so the only thing you kind of
the only thing you were kind of judging
is like the sauce right the chicken
quality at that at that local Tampa one
that Charlie got us was like the chicken
itself tastes so much
it was so it was like the perfect
moistness it wasn't too much batter but
there was a shitload of chicken and the
sauce oh but I heard you like Hershey's
chocolate is this true no oh Cindy said
you love Hershey's
ah when did she say is or is love a
strong word two days ago two days ago
yeah
I think I understand why though
fundamentally why God was so sick of
chicken tandies because he doesn't eat
sauce
is like what the [ __ ] what are you doing
don't even bother but like there's like
this there's so much to chicken like the
okay here's the thing why I don't like
chicken tendies okay or no it's not like
I don't like it but like I would prefer
to have other types of chicken because
you remove like one of the best part of
the chicken in my mind which is the skin
because you just like you you get rid of
the skin no and there's like there's
crispiness dude the crispiness the
crispy batter is where it's at bro oh no
[ __ ]
the batteries
the batter is good but the batter with
like the skin Cooks well that's why
that's why you know when when you go to
KFC and you have like anything but
chicken Denny's the best part is the
[ __ ] skin I will say uh I'm sorry
you're going wrong yeah and like there
is when when we had chicken and waffles
and you guys ordered chicken breasts
with your waffles that like triggered me
to no end I I did that to trigger you on
purpose that was like there was like a
list of like you that the only time
where these boys had a choice of which
part of the chicken they would prefer to
have with this with their meal they
could have ordered breasts they could
have ordered Wings they could have
ordered thighs
um and they ordered like two breasts
to be fair I I I chose I chose a breast
and a thigh and I will say the thigh was
definitely better in that instance
chicken tend these is on another level I
like the kitchen the clean how clean
breast tastes yeah compared thigh yeah
um [ __ ] there was something else I just
forgot I'm an idiot um something sauce
sauce thing about the sauces [ __ ] I
forgot
you know what you know what I think
America unequivly does better than
anywhere else what chicken wings
straight up chicken wings are like
ginormous yeah they're they're right I
don't know how the [ __ ] they get clearly
something is going wrong the chicken
wings are like that in the U.S but I I'm
not complaining because they're huge
they're [ __ ] those chickens there's
so much meat on the chicken wing it's
insane they're on their creator Clash
diet it's insane I I
disagree
where do you think does chicken wings
better than us uh Korea
to me like to me like wouldn't that just
be the sorcer yeah sorry wouldn't that
just be the source no no no no it's it's
not the sauce right it's like they like
the Yum Yum Chicken it's it's like you
know it can be a uh mixture between like
the meat to skin ratio the meat so like
like a batter ratio you know I feel like
the chicken wings in uh America there's
like too much meat that it [ __ ] up with
the ratio of like the marinade right oh
God I'm I'm I I love I love Korean fried
wings so much but God damn do those
American Wings go hard like they go so
much harder I I'd say like what I think
America does better than anywhere else
in the world is barbecue I was like I
will give American barbecue as the best
barbecue in the world I think America
does the best part I mean this I really
want to try like uh Caribbean barbecue
and that kind of that kind of area yeah
because I know that they are well you
know I had like that uh the Cuban
barbecue oh it wasn't really barbecue
but it was like kind of barbecue-esque
Cuban food in um
it was like the Cuban restaurant we went
to in Miami that was just like nothing
but meat and that's pretty good that
place was that place was pretty crazy
yeah I wouldn't say it's Bobby but it's
like barbecue-esque in terms of like
what's that no bro South Korea has good
Wings they have they have the I'm sure
North Korea has good wings too if they
have any there's definitely no meat on
those bones though
I said that but what are you talking
about don't get me wrong you've been
America you've been in America no you're
like more better more food equals better
I I order from I obviously it's in Japan
but a lot of these like a lot of them
are like Korean chains that are in Japan
and I ordered a bunch dude they're just
too flimsy bro there's no there's no
meat on the bone it's just all skin I I
think the one thing I like about a lot
of like American chicken wing is that
like a lot of the places at least the
ones where you went and it's not Fried
Chicken it's not fried chicken for
starters but like the source is like
separate to the wing right so you can
like dip as much more as little sauce as
you want whereas the Yum Yum Ranch but
like the Yum Yum she doesn't like souls
for example in South Korea it depends on
the sauce
okay okay
that's why I don't belong in America
Midwestern girl how could you not like
wrench is it even possible to not like
Ranch but I'm just like is there more
sauce than just Ranch because I'm like
you don't need anything you don't need
to be I'm I'm not saying there's so much
more variety in like other countries
it's all about one [ __ ] sauce okay
let's go let's go through it all then
honey mustard yeah
yes okay what else what what other
condiments can you eat with a chicken
wing what other condiments can you eat
with a chicken wing oh you don't like
barbecue I actually do I mean I
literally just said American barbecue I
think barbecue works better with like
beef and pork rather than chicken uh
like I said I prefer like there's uh
there's a lot of like Thai chicken wings
as well with like this very it's a very
sour spicy sauce right
um I like the Korean chicken wings as
well with like a little bit of sweet I
like spicy stuff buffalo sauce I do love
buffaloes buffalo wings are the goat I
[ __ ] that's that's the best I just don't
want to drench it too much yeah that's
what I don't like about buffalo sauce
it's like when it's sometimes it's just
too I go too hot I don't get it because
you drench it in the sauce in the ranch
anyway what's the difference the ranch
you need to drench it the rent there
because Ranch is great because rice is
amazing I could drink less it's so good
sauce you can eat the buffalo sauce and
then you want to mix it up you're like
dip it in some ranch yeah you can do
Buffalo and Ranch mixture bomb Oh I'm
like I'm like so what I'm so what I'm
understanding here what I'm
understanding
is that you guys just really [ __ ]
like Ranch no but the wings are amazing
the wings are even without the wrench
are way better than anything yeah you
get like because I'm actually eating
meat yeah whereas like in I disagree
where is
I said I said I think there is like I've
got what was like the biggest wins you
want in America because I'm I'm thinking
about the wings I get in the [ __ ]
Midwest and in in the midwest they are
[ __ ] obese
yeah they're huge These Wings Are
massive yeah that's why it's good I
think I'm like I'm like I I there is
like to me like well you guys you guys
eat chicken breasts right so okay I'm
just I'm just gonna realize like you
[ __ ] love the white meat you [ __ ]
you [ __ ] love that [ __ ] that's what I
love chicken I like a mixture between
like you know the the skin as well I
like a mixture between having the
marinade on it it's not always about
fried sometimes you grill it as well
that's why I love like the massive
chicken wings though because there's so
much meat on one chicken wing with one
chicken wing you can like mix and
matches around being like all right
first bite gonna put some ranchers
and it's just so good dude because okay
do you do you dip your chicken Wings in
the source sometimes sometimes yeah
because to me chicken wings chicken
wings are like you know you've chickened
yeah pre-marinated chicken you dip in
the sauce is [ __ ] chicken tendies
it's nugs not because there's no bugs no
there's no bones right I you know the
reason I like Bones the one with the
bone yeah the one with the bone like the
drumsticks you can dip it in the sauce
oh you're talking about are you talking
about drumsticks I've thought you're
talking about wings easy wings as well
you get a wings as well yeah but like if
you can't get it in the container then
you get the container like pour it on
top just like your [ __ ] fight into it
that's just like and it's good [ __ ]
that's not I thought that was like the
one advantage of having boneless chicken
which is that you can just it's just
yeah why do you think we love boneless
chicken because of the convenience I can
eat everything but if the wing is there
then I'm gonna be like well if there's
only Wings here then I'm obviously gonna
eat it because I like wings as well but
it's a little bit inconvenient for me to
have to grab the sauce and pour it on
top that's it and I'm just like the the
[ __ ] advantage of wings is that
normally it's early candies I can just
get straight into that [ __ ] it's like
perfectly shaped to fit the container
normally the advantage of wings is that
it just tastes good by itself it's
already marinated or it's already got
sauce you don't have to dip it in yeah I
like it sometimes with it with and
without it's just a different flavor you
want to mix it up yeah you want to mix
it up it's clam take on it what I'm what
I'm like discovering right now is that
these two just doesn't they don't care
about the taste of the chicken it's all
about the taste of the sauce you know
that's that's what do you mean no one
eats chicken wings with no sauce or dry
rub or anything that's psychotic are you
Dr you there's dry rubs yeah no no
you're not and you know literally the
[ __ ] Wings we had in the office from
like that male in cook they were dry
rubs no I know I like that yeah I'm not
arguing against them sometimes you want
to put more sauce on it yeah why is it
so hard to comprehend sometimes I wanna
I I like the option of additional shoes
if I want extra sauce or not sometimes
you know I'm in the mood where I'm like
I don't need the extra sauce because it
already tastes good enough sometimes I
want a little more yeah but like what
I'm what I'm trying to say is what I
think good wings are well I think good
chicken is is that it should taste good
you know by itself if you are putting
too much sauce in it then you're not
really judging the chicken you're
judging the sauce which is like which is
like my biggest pet peeve with a lot of
like chicken places
because the chicken wing sucks no amount
of sauce is Gonna Save it yeah I'm not
gonna eat it
I think we like the taste of the chicken
we just like it also it yeah we enhanced
yeah I like I already like the taste of
the chicken but with the sauce it's like
an added bonus yeah yeah but if the
chicken wing sucks no amount of ranch is
going to save that [ __ ] ah you I don't
know man with the amount of ranch I see
Americans put on their chicken wings I
it just seems like putting a [ __ ] ton of
ranch is not a choice it's the default
unless that's one and you know what I'm
glad
that's what I saw right it's it's not
even about how good the wings are it's
about how much sauce you put on it and
I'm just looking multiple times
throughout the tour where all I had to
say was Ranch and I got an entire crowd
chant everyone loves Ranch everyone
loves Ranch
thankfully you're the minority question
is boys what's the tour of success oh
massive success I mean a better question
Robert is would we do it again yeah I
think a lot of people you know in Europe
and Southeast Asia would want a tour and
uh they were very vocal about how
annoyed they were they didn't get it
yeah and they were like I don't care
about the tool I don't see anything
about it the amount of Europe tour wins
yeah southeast Asia we're definitely
considering stuff like that because the
first one went so well yeah I think yeah
I mean I think uh I don't know if this
can be a spoiler but we we recorded some
of the shows and we're gonna we're gonna
put some of them on YouTube uh but I
think even after that one thing I liked
about the tour was that we got to learn
about each place we went to and there's
so many more places and so many more
shows I want to do in different places
to like learn about what goes on in that
place the culture of that place and I
think if we were to do another tour we
probably would not do exactly the same
format or exactly the same show but
we'll we would probably take aspects of
this show and try to do it you know in a
more worldwide uh worldwide more places
worldwide I think one thing as well that
again like you know was a great thing to
come out of doing this tour is the fact
that we've learned so much about how to
put on a performance in a stage setting
yeah which I think is really valuable
and uh you know it's you know I
personally learned a lot of skills doing
shows on stage that you know I can
utilize on trash test recordings or like
you know just regular videos and stuff
like that right and it's like it's just
like a cool and also you know like it's
just a cool thing to be like yeah I went
around America doing shows and [ __ ] like
that on stage it was pretty dope yeah
like it's just like a cool story and
experience and you know like from the
amount of stories we've already told
just from this episode it's like
invaluable yeah I I will say if we do a
show again we'll probably do less shows
yeah
23 was too much 23 was too much too much
I got back and like I haven't like
streams haven't even tweeted because I
was just like I need a period in my life
where I just don't have an audience
watching me I was like I just I just
don't need an audience right now and I
was just like chilling out just doing
nothing
um and
that's because 23 shows is way too much
also I think I was like the only one
that actually got ill on the tour as
well I got sick twice oh okay I got sick
once right before we started and I was
like oh no please
towards the end yeah it's like I think I
had to like perform like the last few
shows with like a pretty bad fever which
was difficult but hopefully I I got told
that no one really noticed it no no you
hit it very well yeah but that's because
like I was literally in like I was
literally in Sage Mode the entire day I
didn't see any of these boys I was just
like by myself on the bus conserving
energy for this two-hour show because I
was like dying in bed it was in monk
mode yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
I was like Gathering energy I was like
you can do with this gun you can do this
um so yeah 23 shows is a lot uh probably
to do less shows but I I I would
definitely want to do more shows yeah
hell yeah for sure
yeah I enjoyed it it was just too long
yeah yeah but the last Slide the past
like last week we week and a half two
weeks I was kind of like all right
everybody ready to go home now yeah
think about Japan okay yeah I missed
Japan yeah I think though I think I'm
just glad that like you know I because
again this was our first tour ride so I
think we all three of us weren't really
too sure if we were gonna bro I did not
know what I actually experience it like
nothing you know just we'd heard from
other people about like how tours went
but it's like you know not every tour is
the same kind of thing right so you know
I was just hoping I'm like please
I just want to come out of this tour
liking what I went through yeah luckily
I did so I think it was like awesome
it's like you know I think a lot of
YouTubers
um and streamers whatever they often get
in the Trap of like never leaving their
house and you're just making stuff in
your home and I feel like you're selling
a lot of really cool life experiences
that could enhance maybe even your
content or how you view the world well
for sure and allow you to learn and
expand your horizons you know I think I
think traveling is one of the best ways
to just kind of open your mindset a bit
and learn from other cultures yeah and
so I think it's uh if you get the
opportunity to do it you should always
do it I genuinely learn a lot about
American history yeah I did I feel like
I know a lot more intricacies of the US
now yeah and how States view each other
and how they interact and how States
well they're proud about what they what
they love talking about yeah um and I
think I speak for all of us when I say
this um that you know we're really
grateful to everyone who took like a
gamble on us essentially because we
didn't we'd never taught before there
was absolutely no reason that this was
going to be good there was nothing to
tell value that it was going to be a
good show yeah you know and a lot of
people spent a lot of money spent a lot
of time they were driving you know four
or five hours to come to these shows and
was buying hotels and buying a lot of
tickets and you know just at the uh just
at the opportunity to see us and maybe
hopefully have a good show and uh that
night it was gonna be good yeah um I
hope that we think that uh you know
everyone who came that we made you proud
and that you enjoyed the shows yeah we
really really appreciate the support
yeah I think it uh you know it just kept
blowing me away every time everyone was
like man I traveled five hours to get
here tonight just for this and it's like
yeah damn dude yeah I was crazy thank
you I would not travel five hours
would not travel five hours for me yeah
because at the end of the day you know
all we wanted to do was put a good show
for you guys yeah and that was the only
worry that we had and uh you know we did
our best and we you know and we saw how
uh how well it was received from you
guys and it's that that's [ __ ]
awesome yeah there's definitely some
shows I'm like I'm just too tired but
then you get to the Q a you see how
excited everyone was yeah I gotta put on
the [ __ ] good job yeah no I don't let
these people back but it's all for these
beautiful boys already I know like every
every time I saw that crowd I was like I
just don't want to disappoint I just
don't want to disappoint yeah and no
matter how ill I was or whatever I'm
just like I figured out that if you know
when I see people and I see like like
the dedication and just like how you
guys were just so excited I was just
something awoke and I was just like I
just really really want to make this a
good job yeah I hope we are delivered
yeah I hope everyone who came to the
show had a great time and it was worth
money and time yeah and uh maybe another
tour soon who knows yeah so we'll figure
it out though if we do it won't be
America again yeah right well not right
away Europeans and Southeast Asians like
yeah
yeah I mean I would love to do the show
again and find out more about Europe and
uh yeah 100 yeah but yeah hey look at
all these [ __ ] patrons though they're
also supporting us oh yeah it's been a
while since I've said this Jesus Christ
but uh hey if you want to support us on
patreon then do so by going to
patreon.com trash taste also follow us
on Twitter send us your memes on the
subreddit and if you hate our face
listen to us on Spotify and uh yeah
thank you for your guys continue sport
you've been awesome thank you guys so
much thank you thank you really and uh
we'll see you guys next week it was
actually awesome seeing your faces yeah
finally finally you may you may hear our
faces but we saw yours exactly all right
guys have a good one bye
[Music]
foreign